so there's two big reasons why we're not
public about the Acquisitions number one
me endorsing a company with five 10x the
company overnight if I include a brand
endorsement then I own majority I'm not
going to risk my face on something I
can't control the second thing is that
if we were to exit those businesses and
I had done an endorsement in a minority
position then guess who has to go with
the deal me our whole goal is to build
value in the business so that the
business is sellable and more valuable
and we use my face to bring deals in and
so that's why I've been really really
tight-lipped about the businesses there
are probably some companies in the
future that I will probably endorse I'm
still waiting for the right no strip
company to approach me